bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
matin d'abord dans quel état d'esprit
vous êtes à quelques heures des annonces
du premier ministre
mais si vous voulez moi ce qui m'embête
dans tout ça c'est que j'ai l'impression
que la culture devient la variable de la
crise sanitaire
c'est à dire que parce que on va laisser
les théâtres et les cinémas fermés
les chiffres ne vont pas augmenter ou
vont baisser mais on se marche sur la
tête la ministre de la culture madame
bachelot l'a dit à trois semaines
c'est moins dangereux de faire une
réunion de d'aller au théâtre que de
faire une réunion de famille au théâtre
on a des masques du début à la fin ou au
cinéma
on a dû gel des protocoles ont marché
n'y a pas eu de clusters dans nos salles
donc on ne comprend pas en fait si vous
vous laissez plus ça pour quoi nous
laisser fermées et les c est ouvrir les
autres on entendait les français là ils
en ont tous ras-le-bol ils ont tous le
moral dans les chaussettes
il ya une manière super simple messieurs
du gouvernement de leur redonner un peu
de baume au coeur de morale dans cette
cette période angoissante c'est d'ouvrir
justement les cinémas les théâtres qui
sont des lieux sûrs encore une fois il
n'y a pas eu de plaster c'est dans
toutes les enquêtes nous sommes en bas
tout en bas des lieux contaminants
soi-disant contaminants donc ya pas de
contamination dans nos lieux donc
ouvrait nous et redonner le moral aux
français justement ils pourront aller
rire ils pourront se créer des émotions
cinéma et au théâtre
voilà ce que j'ai envie de dire la
décision est sans doute pas totalement
prise encore donc ne fait pas ça ne nous
privez pas de ça et surtout pourquoi
si vous le faites expliquez-nous
pourquoi parce que nous on ne comprend
pas on a tous compris jusque là mais ça
on ne le comprend pas et si justement
les théâtres les lieux de culture devait
ne pas réouvrir quelles seraient les
conséquences pour le secteur
c'est une catastrophe parce que d'abord
c'est une catastrophe en termes de
communication nous depuis trois semaines
on communique et tout le monde
d'ailleurs un vous aussi les médias sur
le fait que ça va rouvrir quand les gens
ont racheté des places on a on a
remobilisé nos artistes on a remis nos
salariés on les a enlevées du chômage
partiel pour préparer ces ouvertures
ça s'ouvre pas comme ça s'ouvre pas du
jour au lendemain donc c'est une
catastrophe parce qu'on a dépensé de
l'argent et on va devoir rembourser nos
clients et donc on avait déjà un une
trésorerie fragile
les mois de décembre c'est un mois
énorme pour les théâtres et là on nous
prive de ça donc c'est une catastrophe
nos adhérents sont dans un état moral
terrible et là je reçois des coups de
fil de partout icc on sait pas comment
on va s'en sortir mais surtout le plus
dur à dans tout ça c'est d'abord ça fait
trois jours qu'on nous dit on va pas
rouvrir on va rouvrir l'ascenseur
émotionnel est horrible et surtout
pourquoi on ne comprend pas pourquoi
dans le cas justement où ce soir il y
aurait une bonne nouvelle pour votre
secteur est ce que vous êtes prêt à
instaurer un nouveau protocole sanitaire
éventuellement on est prêt à tout mais
le protocole sanitaire vous savez il est
tellement déjà fragile en terme
d'économie parce qu'on est des sociétés
privées donc il faut aussi voir
l'économie si c'est pour ouvrir et
perdre de l'argent mais là le protocole
il fonctionne n'y a pas besoin de
changer d'ailleurs il nous avait dit il
ya trois semaines
sarr ouvrira le 15 si les chiffres sont
bons dans un protocole qui est déjà
acquis mais en fait on ne comprend pas
pourquoi moi je ne comprends pas
pourquoi dans un centre commercial je
peux aller faire quatre heures de queue
pour aller dans un grand magasin qui ne
sert pas à grand chose un qui n'est pas
un magasin forcément de première
nécessité et pourquoi je peux pas aller
dans un théâtre alors que le théâtre est
encore une fois dans un protocole
sanitaires strictes et n'est pas un lieu
contaminants justement l'économie du
secteur aujourd'hui
s'agissant des théâtres quelle est la
situation
alors on a été aidé on nous a dit qu'on
allait nous aider certains théâtres ont
déjà été aidé d'autres l'argent n'est
pas encore arrivé pour plein de raisons
ça serait beaucoup trop lourd à vous
expliquer donc globalement si vous
voulez le secteur est aidée mais c'est
surtout que le mois décembre s'ils nous
prive de sa et du 31 et de tout le reste
est du mois de janvier ce sont les
meilleurs moi c'est comme si vous
fermiez un restaurant de plage en
juillet et en août
voilà c'est pas dur vous fermez les
théâtres là maintenant c'est comme si
vous fermiez un restaurant de plage
juillet août
donc on fait tout notre chiffre pour
rester ouverts le reste de l'année
donc c'est dramatique il va falloir
encore nous aider encore plus nous aider
ou alors on craint justement il ya
beaucoup d'intermittents du spectacle
dans votre secteur ils se disent oubliés
du gouvernement notamment en ce qui
concerne les aides alors moi je serai un
peu plus un peu plus comment dire enfin
je suis pas sûr qu'il soit totalement
oubliés ils ont quand même leur année
blanche jusqu'au 31 août
mais c'est que vous savez c'est toute
une filière on parle des intermittents
laisser les artistes et les auteurs
et puis c'est tout le monde sait les
restaurants les bars tout tout tout le
monde autour on est tous dans cette
situation l'important aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment de dire qu'on peut pas être
cette variable d'ajustement de cette
crise sanitaire nous juste les théâtres
les cinémas
après le reste les débats sur les êtres
c'est encore très compliqué mais les
intermittents ils ont quand même eu leur
année blanche jusqu'à fin août
est-ce qu'il faut la prolonger ça c'est
un autre débat merci beaucoup à vous
loïc bonnet d'avoir répondu en direct à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association des théâtres
privés en région